bonjour de natal vous êtes prêt de
cramât torse qu est-ce que les taurus se
resserre un peu plus chaque jour
oui les forces russes progresse
lentement dans le donbass mais
clairement elle accentue leur tenaille
autour de cette région est sûre sur le
front nord notamment au prédisent une
les bombardements et les tirs
d'artillerie et s'intensifie
il ya deux jours avait camarades à
mehdaoui nous étions sur les positions
très bien mais il semble tout de même
que ces fonds sucré diène sont toujours
en mesure d'opposer une résistance
sérieuse face à cette avancée russe nous
avons dû nous avons vu beaucoup de temps
que sur place et aussi beaucoup de lance
missiles antichars stockées dans une
base une chrétienne et puis sur le front
est ce vous l'avez mentionné il ya
maintenant des combats très intenses à
l'intérieur de la ville clé de ces
verrous donne y est que les russes
tentent de pousser vers l'ouest vers
licite chance que de l'autre de l'autre
côté du fleuve d'eau n'y est ce que
c'est un lycée de chances que nous
étions justement hier avec un marc à la
médaille